now let's move on to other news now and
world leaders are meeting in Germany to
discuss Global security policies the
main topic at the Munich security
conference Russia's invasion of Ukraine
the conflict has led to a change in
policies across Europe including
commitments to increase weapon
deliveries to Kiev for the first time
Russia and Iran have not been invited to
the summit
um to go Ukraine's president of Vladimir
zielinski delivered a video message to
leaders gathered at the conference
we have to liberate Ukraine and Europe
because when the Russian weapon shoot at
us it is already pointed at our
neighbors May Europe be the subject of
compromise no we have to liberate from
Russia's aggressive potential potential
every International institution and
every tier of the world economy because
because only only then there will be a
chance for freedom to pass through our
border further to the east
well let's cross now to our diplomatic
editor James Bates who's been monitoring
events in Munich James tell us more
about what's been going on
well president zielinski is the one
who's opened the Munich security
conference which goes on for the next
few days and it's worth reminding you
Nick you heard president zenski there
speaking by video link while I was
standing in this very position a year
ago and president zielinski was here in
Munich attending the Munich security
conference and that was just days before
the Russian invasion in fact I remember
watching president zielinski leave
through the door behind me get his
limousine and some of the people I spoke
to afterwards were saying they're
wondering whether they would ever see
President zielinski outside his country
ever again well of course he has gone
outside his country and he's still more
importantly in office in Kiev and so I
think that's why this address exactly
one year on was uh very important pretty
similar language as we've seen from
president zinanski in his recent
speeches for example when he spoke
recently in London in Paris and Brussels
messages to the International Community
to do more making the point that what is
lacking here is speed he keeps asking
four things it started with non-lethal
assistance that the West was giving it
moved to heavier weapons then to
artillery and now tanks and now he's
calling for fighter jets but everything
he asks for that there's been a long
period of delay discussion and
eventually uh the West gives him what he
wants but he would like to see the
delivery of weapons speeded up much much
more
Ukraine will stay the top issue I think
during this year's Munich security
conference but it's not just what's
discussed here in terms of a sort of
talk Fest it's also active diplomacy
that sometimes takes place on these
occasions the U.S delegation uh
represented by vice president Kamala
Harris but the U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinking is going to be here too
as is the top foreign policy official of
China Wang Yi the state councilor Wang
Yi and given all the tension over Taiwan
and more recently over the Chinese shot
down over at North American airspace
there is the possibility of discussions
between those two which of course is
something to watch very closely
all right James thanks for that James
Bay is there in Munich